welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for our presentation titled
cancer in the era of covet 19 public
health perspectives it's my pleasure to
introduce you
to you our featured speaker dr tala
al-russon
federal is an internal medicine
physician
an epidemiologist who designs and
develops
large-scale population studies to
understand and evaluate
public health interventions she is
currently an assistant professor at the
herbert
wertheim school of public health and
human longevity
at the university of california san
diego for a complete biography of our
speaker please visit the
tab at the top of your screen if you
have any questions that arise during the
presentation
we encourage you to submit it in the q
and a box
our speaker will address your questions
following this presentation
please join me in welcoming dr tala
al-russon i will now
turn the presentation over to her
welcome
thank you so much susie thank you for
being here today um
my name is tala alverson i will be
discussing uh
cancer in the era of kobe 19 from a
public health
perspective
my disclosure the support for this
program is provided by abbott
and the information presented here is
based on my own interpretation of the
evidence
and clinical experience
so just a little refresher to remind us
all of
coronaviruses and the noble
2019 coronavirus pandemic
so coronaviruses are important human and
animal pathogens
as we all know they've been here with us
and lived
on this planet for a long time and have
caused
some other pandemics and outbreaks such
as the spanish flu in 1918
in 2019 a novel coronavirus was
identified
and has caused the pandemic that we know
of today which is copenhagen pandemic
the virus that is causing this pandemic
is designated as severe experience
syndrome chronovirus ii
or staroscopic ii the problem with this
virus is that it's highly contagious
and um vaccines do not seem to cause
long-lasting immunity for it um
just like the flu virus um we are yet to
understand how to develop long lasting
humidity for it
um also there are disparities in
incidence and mortality rates
that make control very difficult up
until today there are more than 900 000
people that have
died due to covet 19 worldwide
um and we believe that it will be
as they say a marathon uh trying to
combat this pandemic rather than
an easy task
so the pandemic has impacted all areas
of daily life as you know it
including medical care so the delivery
care model has been impacted especially
for cancer patients in many ways
there are competing risks as we know it
um
cancer patients are immunocompromised
which
puts them at great risk for contracting
the virus
and uh for dying from it um there are
interruptions to care for passion for
patients with cancer as well as the lack
of resources
so so many people now have been
reshuffling resources
in a way that has impacted cancer
patients negatively
and we'll be discussing that in more
depth um
as they say there is no one size that
fits all approach to delivering care
so for cancer patients as you know we're
talking about personalized medicine
we're talking about different case by
case uh type of
of care that is impacted of course by
all this interruption um to care
um as well as the problem of having no
international guidelines
of course because it's a new pandemic we
are still struggling
to really have a centralized approach to
dealing with it when it comes to cancer
patients
so now we're seeing a lot of
drive-through blood draw injections
um we're seeing some staff travel
restrictions
social distancing in waiting rooms and
work areas
new screening procedures and laws when
it comes to
cancer patients who are in active
treatment and those who are screening
for cancer
and of course we're seeing the major
shift to telemedicine and virtual
check-ins
so patients with cancers as we said are
one of the groups that are most impacted
by the pandemic for two main reasons
number one is that they are
immunocompromised so there is some
status of systematic immunosuppressive
state
that these patients have and number two
the requirement for
frequent admission to the hospital which
of course
increases the risk of getting the virus
as we know or as we may expect incident
cancer diagnosis may increase during
or after the pandemic due to halted
screening
so of course screening is being impacted
the most during this
pandemic one would think and again we
will be discussing this in today's talk
in more depth
but this is a time for us to think ahead
and develop evidence-based guidelines
from management
um the big question in research right
now is that
does cancer increase one's risk of
contracting
chronovirus and getting covered or is it
the other way around
patients who get covered um
are at increased risk of developing
cancer
um and i think it's a mixture of both
really so both sides of the story could
be true and there's a lot of research
and resources now
heading into that direction to really
try to answer these questions
so we know that cancer increases
risk for covid through um
immunodeficiency so
cancer patients are immunocompromised
usually
certain cancers like lung cancer there
is already a pre-damaged lung
so we're expecting um covid to present
itself
in more severe form in lung cancer
patients
as well as of course the comorbidities
that cancer patients usually have such
as hypertension
diabetes and of course the frequent
hospitalization of cancer patients
increases the risk of contracting the
virus while being hospitalized
and also a big question remains is that
what happens if someone gets coveted and
now
you know looking at different disease
models we don't understand
on the long term if someone contracted
the virus would they have some lingering
effect
for example some research now is showing
that coped might have some
um you know cause some brain damage
we know now that um
there is an increased inflammation
resistant chronic inflammation status to
due to covid we know that
the virus enters the cell through
the ace receptors or the angiotensin
converting enzyme receptors
so it really does affect the
biochemistry of cells
um so could that promote oncogenic
transformation could cells
become more cancerous at a higher rate
or
at an earlier stage so that's a question
that is um out there for researchers and
now they're actively
seeking answers for it
so what's the global burden of cancer we
know now that
almost 18 million people or a little
over 18 million people in the world
have cancer um and the projections
are that in 2040 more than
27 million people will have cancer so
that's a big jump
um and cancer accounts for 8.8 million
deaths
annually uh 70 of these deaths happen
and occur in low and middle-income
countries
so in the grand scheme of things one in
five men
and one in six women have cancer
or have had cancer at some point in low
life
and that one in eight men and one in 11
women
die of cancer so it's a huge
global burden
um this burden as we said is expected to
grow
and it's even expected to grow
exponentially at a
higher pace in less developed countries
than in more developed countries
so asia we know accounts nearly for half
of all cancer cases now um and more than
half of cancer deaths were would and we
believe that asia and africa
have higher proportion of cancer death
compared
with their incidence meaning that they
have higher frequency of cancer types
that have poorer prognosis
as well as limited diagnosis training
and treatment capabilities
which makes these countries really a
higher
risk of developing a larger global
burden
of cancer so why are we expecting more
people to be diagnosed with cancer
for two reasons reason number one is the
population growth
so we know that the population is
growing
worldwide reason number two is they're
getting older
right so um aging also global aging is a
major issue
as well as the risk factors of course so
here in the uk for example they've done
research modeling and predicting
the numbers of people that
will have cancer in 2035
and cancers due to risk factor changes
only
so by looking at numbers only if people
um you know there's a large number of
people
that will get cancer because of
population growth but also because of
risk factors and how we're
you know our life is changing technology
how we're having more sedentary
lifestyles obesity
that all is also contributing to
this picture of having larger prevalence
rates and incidence rates of
cancer
also there are certain types of cancer
that are
clearly underfunded in terms of research
like lung cancer
so we know that lung cancer accounts for
13 of new cancer diagnoses
almost quarter of all cancer deaths are
due to lung cancer
and the survival beyond five years is
really low when it comes to lung cancer
however when you think about funding or
look at the funding and the numbers
only six percent of federal research
dollars
are designated to look at lung cancer
and research lung cancer
um how is this pandemic affecting cancer
research
so a survey by the american cancer
society
surveyed about 488 funded cancer
researchers here in the united states
and it showed reduced cancer research
capacity and efficiency
so most of them are not being able to
resume their research of course due to
lockdowns
and due to underfunding and other
registration again we'll talk about this
a little more
later on we also know that pre-pandemic
there were clear disparities in cancer
screening
so for example whites are 32
more likely to be up to date with um
cancer screening such as colorectal
cancer
than american indians or alaska natives
um we know that women in the highest
income
bracket are more likely to be up to date
with cervical cancer
breast cancer screening than women and
the lower income
um we know that women who have private
health insurance are more than twice as
likely to be up to date with
with screening too so
these disparities exist they exist on a
global level
socioeconomic status where you live so
many things
impact how much you know about cancer
and how often you screen
and how you receive your care
what about cancer and numbers during the
pandemic
so in england they did this national
population based modeling study
looking at different cancer
prevalence rates and incidence rates
they looked at
breast cancer lung cancer especially
cancers
and by looking at the wait time in
emergency presentation
and how much care these cancer patients
are receiving
they have seen more
deaths of cancer of course again because
people are not screening
they're delaying care there's an
interruption to care so there was
seven to ten percent more deaths in
breast cancer
fifteen to sixteen percent more deaths
and lung cancer
and four to five point three in
esophageal cancer
so again this pandemic is really
impacting
cancer patients disproportionately
and recently only last month there was a
study
by jama by the journal of the american
medical association
that showed that more well they
studied more than 200 thousand cancer
patients
they looked at pre-pandemic and current
incidence rates of many types of cancer
and this study in particular has shown
significant decline in newly identified
cancers
so unlike what one would predict we are
not able to pick up these numbers
that's why we are seeing lower insulin
rates of cancer during the genetic
findings were also similar from two
studies from the netherlands cancer
registry which is a national cancer
registry as well and very representative
of
the people of netherlands as well as the
uk
um where one study has shown 75
declining referrals from for suspected
cancer since coped
restrictions were implemented
so this is a jama study where people
have looked at numbers researchers have
looked at numbers
between march and april as the new as
you can see
the newly identified patients numbers
have decreased exponentially
for almost all these types of cancers
since the pandemic has hit
so how does one provide safe care for
patients during these challenging times
the american society of cancer clinical
oncology
and cdc have offered some guidance
through guidelines that they have come
together and put together
these guidance these guidelines offer
guidance on general healthcare
facility and healthcare professional
guidance clinical care guidance
home care guidance and what
do we do to high risk self-population
so certain types of cancers
it seems like in general any clinic
visit that can be postponed
is being postponed so routine
surveillance physics like mammograms
colonoscopy are being postponed now so
you do
the lockdown and the mitigation
containment efforts that we're using for
this pandemic
um screening clinics are being developed
to allow for patients with symptoms to
be evaluated
and tested before entering the facility
so the goal is if there is a covet
patient
you need not to get them inside facility
there are concerns about the halt in
national screening programs in most
countries and we know japan for example
has a national cancer screening program
that is excellent
even that is being halted now and
stopped before because of
the endemic and this has
impact on future cancer mortality as we
said
so one should think of these numbers and
what happens since people are not
being able to go and screen for the
cancers
so the backlog of patients with symptoms
will happen once we are into this
pandemic
and we start to loosen the lockdown
measures that we're taking
and systems have to be prepared for that
now for the anti-cancer treatments also
there is of course
delaying the elective surgeries that
people are having such as reconstructive
breast surgery etc
those are our are all being delayed
um usually they're resumed if infection
rates are downward for at least two
weeks
and if um if resources can be
um you know looked at in a way that a
hospital now feels okay
with returning patients to with elective
surgeries
also you know scheduling of cases and
prioritization
of cases is usually managed by all
stakeholders so
different you know surgeons and doctors
who are internally medicine doctors
they all have to create to return this
patient for elective surgeries
for radiation therapy randomized
clinical trials
now support deferring also radiation
therapy across a multitude of cancers
and they tend to place systemic therapy
first in the treatment sequence
overall for chemo immunotherapy and
systematic there is no direct evidence
to support changing or withholding
chemotherapy or immunotherapy
however it's case-by-case phases and of
course it depends on the
provider and the place where someone is
receiving their
treatment so of course
um you know alchem and some
other researchers have come together
under an
international collaboration group to put
some guidelines such as the one we're
seeing in front of us
that can guide our decisions
to therapy during these times
also it's worth mentioning that this
shift of telehealth
is impacting patients a lot especially
cancer patients
um so now providers are thinking of
how to deal with patients through the
video
and phone calls um what kind of
questions they should expect
you know the the notion of empathy and
how do you do that
virtually these are all things that are
new and being
presented to us by this pandemic
we also know that mental health is a big
aspect of cancer patients
and cancer care we know that patients
usually with cancer present with stress
depression
anxiety insomnia denial anger
fear um and there are studies now
certificating
patients uh with cancer um
on um you know how do you feel during
these cohort times or the proto-pandemic
some you know more than half are worried
of course
45 percent are understanding 42 percent
are anxious
many are stressed 43 and 22
are depressed we also have to not ignore
the um the mental health toll on
providers and caregivers family
caregivers providers physicians
are complaining from burnout isolation
worry about own health during coca times
attracting the virus as well as
competing demands at work many doctors
and providers are being pulled into
covert service
or caring for covered patients of course
that comes with
its own mental health challenges
some of the coping mechanisms or
suggested solutions now are to create
coping mechanisms
groups communication guide again like
the one we've seen before
that where providers can learn more on
how to navigate
care using telehealth as well as
supportive measures that could be
offered
to patients
so this is a survey that was done by the
cancer
action network american cancer society
where they surveyed more than 3 000
cancer patients and survivors
on the types of insurance they have
um as well as the burden that kobe 19
is presenting them with so um
49 of all patients surveyed
had employer provided insurance 32
percent had medicare
seven percent were privately insured
four percent were
medicaid and seven percent had no
coverage
at all um and
they asked these patients whether they
were worried
that the financial impact of coping 19
will
cause and will make it harder for them
to afford care
as a cancer cancer survivor of course
the lower the income the more likely you
are to be worried about that about
receiving
care as a cancer survivor during the
time
but also uh those who were in the high
income
as well were worried so 21 which is
almost quarter of
all patients who are in the high income
category were also
worried about receiving less care
as a cancer survivor due to the pandemic
also the effects of kevin 19 health care
were obvious in terms of
almost 27 of respondents who were in
active treatment for cancer
their care or treatments delayed are
cancelled
versus 24 of those who are
could be cancer survivors or um
in between so um it did
impact everyone those who are in active
treatment and those
who are survivors
a cross-sectional study uncovered
infection mortality rate from 396
counties in the united states from seven
states
looked at covid's in cancer patients
and those
who were african-american older
and had increased risk of icu state
intubation were more likely
to contract copenhagen so cancer
patients again
cancer disparities are obvious
the pandemic is shedding the light on
these
disparities which is very important for
us to
kind of have these conversations on
and should guide the way we think about
health and well-being in general
for cancer patients also socio-economic
factors
as we mentioned before as well as other
social determinants of health play a
major role
in explaining these disparities so where
you live what kind of job you have
are you an essential essential worker
that you cannot stay at home
um all of these things explain
much of which what we are seeing due to
the pandemic in cancer patients
so bringing such data to the surface
will help us
understand these structural issues and
understand also who to screen
how to reach these hard to reach
populations and these minority
populations et cetera so
this is the time to be really thinking
about this even
to tackle cancer and accessories
so equitable cancer care is really
something that i think
should be completely emphasized due to
this pandemic
and will be how we think about cancer
care
moving forward so non-communicable
diseases
um you know prevention and control
should be a global
priority although this pandemic is
presenting itself through an infectious
disease
non-communicable disease remain a big
killer worldwide and um
if we do not address that then any virus
in any future pandemic
could really cause what we're seeing
right now and the loss of lives that we
are seeing right now
universal health care should be a human
right and should be re-thought in every
single country
and um i take the code of princess dean
amarando jordan
who is also the president-elect of the
union for international cancer control
her vision is really that we cannot
combat
cancer unless we talk about universal
health care
and about making non-communicable
disease prevention control or global
priority
also improving breast cancer survival is
a big thing
especially in the less developed world
we need to talk more and invest more
in breast cancer survival and we need to
share the global responsibility to
support certain groups
such as refugees with cancer and
hard-to-reach populations
and conflict zones you know all of those
are contributing to the cancer
disparities that we're seeing right now
due to covet
so what if a patient who has cancer
is infected with coping what are the
numbers like what is the picture like
incidence in cancer patients was higher
in studies
from china about three times higher and
from spain about four times higher
however
um also studies from europe have
suggested similar
or lower incidence of
covid19 in cancer patients compared to
the general population
so the evidence on that is mixed and
still
we are yet to capture that in more
studies and more statistics
as we head into the new year
prevalence rates also varied in studies
so um if infected likelihood of severe
illness and death from coping 19 is
higher and that's something you all
agreed about
we talked about how cancer
could increase your risk of
of dying from coping 19 due to the
systemic
immunocompromised state status that
patients have but also the chronic
persistent
inflammation that is believed to happen
due to the disease the coping disease
a meta-analysis study included 32
international studies
and looked at 46 000 patients or more
showed an increased all-cause and
mortality in cancer patients due to
covet
as well as increased icu admissions
and um it is believed that one percent
of all patients with cancer
who has covered have had uh sorry
one percent of all patients who has who
have coped now
have had a history of cancer before
so this is the socio-ecological model
which is really the basics
of public health science and research we
don't think
of health as only individual factors
but rather it's the interpersonal
organizational
community and public policy layers that
all
interplay in dictating one's health and
prognosis
especially when it comes to cancer so
while certain cancers
like lung and hematologic cancers are
associated with increased
risk of mortality from covid19
the social determinants of health by a
major role
in prognosis from coca-19
and that's why we're seeing higher
mortality rates in
as we said patients from racial and
ethnic minorities
those who live in rural areas compared
to those who live in suburban areas
the impact of whether the cancer is
active and whether the patient
is currently receiving treatment also
remains unknown at this point
so some research needs to be done in
that
area
now what's the effect of cancer
treatment in kovid19 severity
um and a recent study also has been
looking at more than 900 patients from
the u.s
canada and spain it showed no higher
30-day mortality rates in cancer
patients who have kelvin 19.
so this is again some um
unlike what we've seen in the previous
studies these
this study is saying that there is no
higher
mortality rates in cancer patients who
have coveted
also a similar study from the uk has
showed similar results
however as we know the type of cancer
and the treatment you're receiving
may influence the risk there was a study
that retrospectively
looked at symptomatic of in 19 patients
who were treated with immune checkpoint
inhibitors
they had threefold the risk of
hospitalization
and severe covet
presentation however cytotoxic
chemotherapy did not show a significant
association
so again these are studies that could
inform our guidelines
on how to manage cancer patients
there are again some challenging types
of cancers like solid tumors
hematologic malignancies and coping 19
together with if someone has these kind
of tumors
and has covered 19 the prognosis is
believed to be worse
um due to older age comorbidities and
immunocompromised status another
challenge
in these patients are um
that some of them are under
cytoreductive treatment or
therapy so patients with lung cancer or
metastatic lesions for example they
might present with symptoms
similar to coca-19 which makes it
difficult
to really manage these patients
also certain type of tumors like brain
tumors and
and um people who have brain cancers
they often have to travel to hospitals
hospitals are
more you know they offer better care and
more advanced care
um so this all impacts
um their quality of life in terms of the
fear of facing this pandemic
with an immune system that is
significantly weakened by the disease by
the treatment as well steroid
radiotherapy or chemotherapy
so what's happening when it comes to
testing and cancer patients
so we usually are doing priority testing
for uh cancer patients who either
present with symptoms
or are exposed to a covet positive
person however if a person has no
symptoms
and have not been exposed to someone who
had covered
it really varies across institutions so
for cancer patients with lower spiritual
symptoms or signs
those who have fever cough dyspnea
we like to proceed with nucleic acid
usually amplification testing
testing would be prepared prior to
highly
suppressive treatments so
[Music]
at some institutions testing of
asymptomatic patients
prior to initiating anti-cancer
treatment is limited to those
who have blood cancers or hematologic
malignancies
many places offer testing to all lung
cancer patients
um and again it varies from one place to
the other from one country to other
based on test availability and resource
availability and what the team
thinks is best and should be done and
how resources should be allocated
so this is really to
discuss more about testing as we know it
there are two types of testing
um testing um
that is viral rna detection
and viral antibody response detection
and both of those testing techniques
have their own
limitations um we know that a return to
chemotherapy criteria
could be entertained once reliable
antibody testing and vital titles are
developed so really false positives and
false negatives and how sensitive
the testing is could dictate
whether we go back to chemotherapy or
not
um as testing becomes more widely
available it may be reasonable to test
all asymptomatic patients um
who will be receiving immunosuppressive
anti-cancer therapy
or who are believed to otherwise be at
risk for serious complications
from covet 19 and the results of such
testing can be informed decisions about
delaying cancer therapy versus not
also testing is very important as we
think about vaccines in the future
so after we develop a vaccine antibody
testing may aid in vaccinating those
with low tighter of
protective antibodies so really
when you think of how cancer patients
present themselves
they're either asymptomatic or
symptomatic
carriers of covid19 so it's very
important to be
developing testing that is uh highly
sensitive and specific and can give us
the accurate answers so that we could
proceed with
our decisions for therapy and what's
next patients would be
cell malignancies like lymphoma or
multiple myeloma
chronic lymphocytic leukemia they will
likely have distinct antibody responses
so those patients may require a
specialized
pathway and specialize um testing
techniques so that's also an area that
is very
important to be researching and doing
patients with a known exposure need to
be tested of course quarantined and
closely
followed up
now we know that due to the restrictions
uh and lockdown and the reallocation of
resources
um clinical trials many cancer clinical
trials
are being halted um we also know that
now
covid is making us rethink how
we um we do discoveries right
so kobe 19 infection has led to
shortening of traditional regulatory
time
timelines this experience should
stimulate
similar urgency in the way future cancer
research is conducted
so hopefully we learn from this pandemic
how to get things on the market
and to patients who need it faster
now what are the lessons the big lessons
that this pandemic is teaching
us first of all invest in public health
it's very hard to invest in something
that you don't see in front of you it's
very hard to prevent
things that's why we are having
difficulty screening for cancers and
asking people to scream
um but hopefully this pandemic is
teaching us that
even if you don't see something that
doesn't mean it's not going to happen
um also underserved population offer
often often suffer from chronic
comorbidities so again
those are and should be our target
populations for
increased screening efforts prevention
research genetic research
these populations have less access to
health care usually for
chronic conditions including cancer and
sometimes
they don't have the ability to shelter
in place as we said
most of them are essential workers so
all of these factors need
to be addressed family members at the
bedside
also is something very important and
we're learning now that
due to covid you know a lot of cancer
patients
unfortunately are are dying without any
family members on their website
on their bedside which is really a big
problem
also icu nurses usually there's shortage
there's shortage of staff so now we need
to invest more in in this field in this
area
of course we need to diversify our
clinical trials more
so providing a valid and vetted
communication channel to get
more minority groups more women
into our clinical trials are extremely
important
so communicating the importance of
clinical research
is extremely important um
and separating signal from noise the
opportunities that having all of this
information creates for data and
technology
to provide meaningful and large-scale
impact
are really large and i think this
pandemic is
helping us rethink how
we can advance cancer therapies and
cancer
technologies and innovation in cancer
care
instead of just looking at the tough
picture of losing
a lot of patients due to cancer due to
halted screening
so again really looking into the
opportunity is something we should be
thinking about
now the greatest challenge is how do we
help people who are afraid to seek care
to begin with
um most of our public health messaging
regarding covet has focused on
mitigation and containment efforts so
social distancing
washing pants ppe um
we also need to um
really think about um
you know whether you have covet or not
we are still here for you so as
systems for cancer patients we need
to really be rethinking how despite all
what's happening
how do we manage these risk versus
benefit i think a great opportunity
for us during this pandemic is to
rethink
breast cancer here so
the following costs of sequencing dna
have created an opportunity for us to
explore new approaches
to screening which incorporate genetic
information
and really it's important now to
to revisit that and think of
um of clinical trials
that can introduce
new therapies and incorporate genetic
information
as the tools and methods for screening
improve doctors can
start to do less screening for people
who are lower risk
this is the way that the field is going
to evolve so we need to put resources to
the people who need them the most
i think mega print essay is really an
interesting
technology so there was an a recent
[Music]
research that was presented at the 2020
american association for cancer research
virtual meeting that happened a few
months ago
and it highlighted how macro mammogram
essay they
effectively got chemotherapy decisions
during the copen19 pandemic
so these technologies could help us
really
make decisions on to move forward or not
so using memory print and hormone
receptor positive patients with
up to three nodes in whom chemotherapy
is considered the treatment
can be limited allowing safe
de-escalation of therapy
without increased cancer specific
mortality
from copen
now eradicating cancer is a big dream
and it's what we all work for
in the cancer community and it lies
in both fields i think the biggest
opportunity is
to work on prevention so prevention
research
is key cancers do not have a single
cause as we know
and um much of the work could be
invested in prevention as well as
genetics research
which is really the holy grail would be
a test that could
pick up the earliest warning signs or
signals of cancer
a popular vision would be to use such
tests in the general population
so hopefully the future would be a test
a genetic test that could be applied to
everyone in the population
so in summary the data is clear and
showing that severe
illness from covet is higher among adult
patients with lung cancer
and certain types of cancer the data is
mixed on other types of cancer
however more research is emerging now
which is really great
and the data on whether recent cancer
therapy impacts severity are
mixed so the most important risk factor
for
uh severe disease usually are things
that have nothing to do with cancer such
as social determinants of health
how old you are where you live how many
core morbidities you have
of course the psychological impact of
this pandemic
on cancer patients and providers
and caregivers is huge um
communication is key so again
in the cancer world and cancer research
it's very important for us to all come
and sit together and
talk such as this summit that hopefully
will
post uh some of the most brilliant minds
in the world to come together and share
um their views on the future now that
this pandemic has been affecting
every aspect of life innovations
and testing and screening for both
cancer and covid
should be hand in hand so we should not
wait on cancer as they say cancer does
not wait
even if there there's a pandemic um
so yes this is again a slide for how
every
um every aspect of the cancer care model
and every stakeholder should come
together and try their best
to not let this pandemic impact
how we research cancer how we
provide new drugs and new therapies or
how we
think of innovations in cancer
if there are take-home messages that i
would like to have from here
from this talk is that the balancing of
risks of delaying cancer versus um
not uh or versus the risk of of coping
19 exposure
are challenging the guidelines are
changing
it is a rapidly changing situation
cancer research should be prioritized
and funded
and should not be you know halted
due to the pandemic clinicians should
proactively discuss
goals of care um and advanced care
planning
including advanced directives especially
for those with advanced cancer who are
at an elevated risk for kelvinine such
as
lung cancer patients
finally this is a picture of mildred
geraldine who um
it was recently featured in the news
here in the united states
um mildred has survived
the 1918 spanish flu
coveted 19 and cancer and
um i know although i painted a little
bit of a tough
image now by showing these statistics of
the global
cancer burden and how this pendant could
be negatively impacting
uh cancer research and advancements i
want us all to be thinking like mildred
it wasn't bad and uh we will get through
this and hopefully
um you know pandemic will actually be
the reset button
that will help us innovate and help us
all come together as a global community
and tackle the global burden of cancer
finally i'd like to acknowledge princess
dina who is the president of the union
for international cancer control
the global cancer oncology the european
society for medical oncology
our colleagues at the international
agency for research on cancer
as well as my colleagues at the american
society for
clinical oncology
these are my references and thank you so
much for attending this talk
thank you dr al-russon for the
outstanding presentation
we will now move into the live q and a
portion
of the presentation as a reminder please
submit your questions via the q and a
box
so let's take a look i see some
questions already
in our q a dr oliver's on
in africa there are no clear guidelines
on what to do when a patient with cancer
on chemotherapy
develops a fever what would be your
advice to that
thank you so much for that great
question um and hello to my colleagues
in africa
um it's a great question you know we
cannot ignore the
possibility of a cancer patient
developing
malaria typhoid what if someone presents
with those
and he has cancer um should
we call the overstretched and under
resourced covid19
team you know the paucity of
protective uh personal protective
equipment and year and on-site testing
kits
for patients and healthcare staff
um on the continent of africa is a major
flaw in delivering life-saving care for
cancer patients um i think
the availability of logistics which are
greatly inadequate
um institutional guidelines and the
country-specific
carbon-19 case burden um will dictate
actions so really africa is a large
continent
and each country is dealing with a
pandemic
i know in west africa for example the
covenanting protocols are defined by
individual institutions however in south
africa
who are now dealing with local epidemics
small local epidemics
um of concern is hiv um
and um a tb which includes approximately
eight million people who live
uh with hiv in south africa so
so far cancer care is impacted on
competing risks as we said um
oncologists in africa
despite the absence of a centralized
guideline or plan they are actually
pragmatically
safeguarding their patients and
workforce
um it's a difficult task there is no um
perfect answer for this however i feel
despite the scarcity of resources
they're doing a great job
thank you and dr robuson you've touched
your talk
on screening in regards to
thinking about kuba testing how
important in your opinion
is screening to cancer and this is a
two-part question
how would screening change the cancer
picture in the future
that's a great question as we mentioned
during this talk screening has been
halted
due to pandemic and we feel that
screening is extremely important for
cancers you know we pick up cancer
at an earlier stage we reallocate
resources
the way they should be allocated so they
go to patients who really need
to be treated cancer so the whole idea
is that
um screening should be invested in more
and more
and this pandemic is showing that
actually despite
uh the fact that we're halting springing
patients are being impacted and we will
see this
backlog in the future so we will see
more cancer patients presenting because
of these lack of screening so for
example for something like colorectal
cancer
screening could really impact survival
and could impact which stage you pick up
a cancer
so screening is something that should be
invested in heavily
worldwide whether there is a pandemic or
not
from my own perspective screening should
be always prioritized
thank you and do you see cancer testing
moving
into home testing using testing kits
just like covet 19 testing changed in
such a short period of time
for sure and i think during this talk
that was the main
point that we're trying to emphasize so
again
we're seeing testing as an innovative
testing techniques that could be genetic
that could pick up signals
early on and that could be distributed
to the entire population
so the future should look something like
this if we want to
really tackle the global burden of
cancer testing should be widely
available for everyone
testing should be advanced in the sense
that
it could pick up signals very early on
it could pick up our transformation and
genetic material
of cells earlier
thank you so i would guess then you see
cancer testing
in the future changing to home testing
that's exactly right thank you so much
and we have
time for one more question it seems from
your talk
that cancer research may face a
recession
because of the pandemic can you
elaborate on that
and what should be done to avoid that
from happening
thank you for that question um yes
well the exponentially increasing
numbers of our article published
since february 2020 um related to cancer
and the covenanting pandemic have really
focused much on risk production
and management of cancer patients during
this outbreak
as well as really characterizing um
cancer patients
again epidemiologically talking about
statistics and
um which cancer patients suffer the most
um and um etc so really
we are mostly thinking in a myopic way
at this point just really trying to
um thinking about coping 19 and a cancer
patient
however i think the priority of oncology
researchers
during this pandemic should not be only
on
uh covered in chain among cancer
patients
um this is something we're seeing in
other fields of research as well
we call it the coconutization of
research
at this point really i understand that
most governments
are trying to secure their citizens and
they want to make sure that the loss of
lies and the numbers
are not high up of those who die of
coven however um
a load of research and publications and
new trials
uh in oncology should be
to um you know motivate cancer
researchers
to get back on track get back to work
once
the restrictions are loosened and to
keep to keep
um innovating and to keep their new
trials
um cancer in general working and going
on
because again cancer cannot wait
very true thank you again dr el russon
for this
incredible presentation and for your
important research
thank you for the audience for
outstanding questions
we hope you found today's presentation
informative
and insightful this presentation will be
available on demand viewing
and don't miss out on the other valuable
presentations on our agenda
visit the agenda tab in the auditorium
for the full
listing thank you again for your
participation until next time be safe
stay healthy take care bye